der Junge aus St Petersburg der Sohn
eines
fabrikarbeiters der der heute die
Ukraine in Schutt und Asche legt seit
mehr als 7 Monaten ja seit mehr als 7
Monaten lässt er auch Kindergärten und
Krankenhäuser bombardieren dieser Junge
aus St Petersburg der will sich heute
feiern lassen 70 Jahre alt und ein paar
wenige politische Freunde hatte dann
doch noch gefunden die er heute
eingeladen hat in seine Heimatstadt St
Petersburg Wladimir Putin 70 was wünscht
man so einem Mann der uns alle bedroht
zum Geburtstag das sind ihre Antworten
die Frage ist wirklich nicht zu
beantworten die ist so eindeutig aber
man mag es nicht aussprechen was ich ihm
Wünsche
[Gelächter]
wow wow
Essen
Einsicht Einsicht in die dramatischen
Entscheidungen die er gefaltet gefällt
hat dass er halt der Krieg beendet würde
ich sagen und dass er nicht diese blöde
Referendums macht die gar nicht frei
sind in der Ukraine
das hat zur Vernunft kommt
weil er doof ist ich wünsche ihm dass er
untertauchten soll das ermöglicht und
dass wir wieder Frieden bekommen dass er
nicht mehr allzu alt wird
und sonst wünsche ich Ihnen nichts Gutes
das sind ganz viele ganz spontale ganz
ehrlicher Antworten auf der Straße
gewesen in Berlin hier zum 70 von
Vladimir Putin build Reporter
parolzheimer und zugeschaltet aus der
Ukraine sowie sie das kennen ja Putin 70
Paul was wünschst du diesem Mann zum
Geburtstag
ich wünsche ihm dass er endlich vorhin
Kriegsverbrecher Tribunal in Den Haag
gestellt wird und dass all das am Ende
Konsequenzen hat was er hier Grausames
getan hat was er befohlen hat was er
sein Soldaten befohlen hat die vielen
Kriegsverbrechen die wir hier selbst
gesehen haben die Tatsache dass er ein
Land angegriffen hat und so viel Horror
in dieses Land gebracht hat der Vladimir
Putin der lässt sich dann heute feiern
in St Petersburg zusammen 70 geburtstag
wie erlebt die Ukraine diese ja
Inszenierung diese Momente
die Ukraine interessiert sich nicht so
wirklich dafür wie Wladimir Putin sein
Geburtstag feiern allerdings ist klar
dass man hier von Wladimir Putin auch in
der Frage einer Lösung dieses Krieges
nichts wissen will wo du mir selensky
hat gesagt mit Wladimir Putin wird er
nicht mehr verhandelt egal was passiert
er hat sogar ein Dekret unterschrieben
und dass das Ganze ausschließt also in
der Ukraine setzt man darauf dass es
irgendwann ein Regimewechsel gibt und
dass man dann mit einem neuen russischen
Präsidenten verhandeln kann der
amerikanische Präsident Paul der spricht
der warnt vor einem Armageddon hat
dieses Wort benutzt in den vergangenen
Stunden
ja Joe Biden spricht das erste Mal sehr
sehr klar von einer atomaren Drohung
neben ihm hat ja auch zum Beispiel
kannst du ein Angela Merkel gestern
gesagt man dürfte das nicht als Bluff
abtun was Putin dort gesagt hat und
gleichzeitig lässt dann das natürlich
der Schaudern wenn man auf die
historischen Vergleiche von Joe Biden
hört zur Kubakrise er sagt die Gefahr
sei so groß wie seit langem nicht mehr
dass das passiert und diese Frage eben
ob Russland eine taktische Atomwaffe
einsetzen könnte die beschäftigt
natürlich die ganze Ukraine Freunde von
mir
diskutieren wie man sich darauf
einstellt was man machen sollte wenn
dieser Atomschlag passieren würde ich
stehe jetzt gerade hier in Kiew auch
hier beschäftigen sich die Leute damit
obwohl es ja mittlerweile relativ weit
weg ist von der eigentlichen Frontlinie
von der wir gerade kommen im Osten das
wahrscheinlichste wenn man denn in
dieses Szenario geht ist das Wladimir
Putin eine also wenn er sich dazu
entscheiden sollte das zu tun dass er
dann eine taktische Atomwaffe sehr
wahrscheinlich an der Frontlinie gegen
Soldaten einsetzen würde
nichtsdestotrotz beschäftigt das ganze
Land was passieren kann danke ein Bild
Reporter Paul Ronzheimer in die Ukraine
an diesem Tag an dem Wladimir Putin sich
wieder inszeniert an seinem 70
Geburtstag aber wie ist aus diesem
Vladimir aus St Petersburg der Mann
geworden der als Putin heute die Ukraine
in Schutt und Asche legt und uns allen
mit seinen Atomwaffen so stark druckt
die trojanische Matroschka Vladimir
vladimirovic Putin
im März 2000 wird der Ex KGB Mann
russlands Präsident spricht ein Jahr
später auf deutsch im Bundestag
versöhnlich betont Demokratie und
Zusammenarbeit sucht offenbar die Nähe
zu Deutschland und Europa jetzt ist dann
der Zeit ist an der Zeit daran zu denken
was zu tun ist damit das einheitliche
und sichere Europa zum Vorboten eine
einheitlichen und sicheren welthund die
Hülle fällt langsam Jahr für Jahr ein
bisschen mehr eine Szene wie diese 20
Jahre später undenkbar
[Musik]
reden wie diese schaffen Vertrauen
vermeintlich Putin baut seinen Einfluss
auch außerhalb Russlands immer weiter
aus seine spätere Waffe gegenüber
Deutschland und der Welt russisches Gas
sein Verbündeter Gerhard Schröder
gasgert der Ex-Bundeskanzler legt den
Grundstein für die Abhängigkeit von
russischem Gas er besiegelt die
deutsch-russische Energiepartnerschaft
eine Mischung aus geostrategischer
Naivität und persönlicher
eingenommenheit die beiden sind Freunde
die energiepolitische Zukunft
Deutschlands liegt spätestens seit 2005
in den Händen Putins Deutschland hängt
seitdem an Putins Gashahn das hat eine
wahrhaft historische Qualität
Deutschland sichert in direkter
Partnerschaft mit Russland große Teile
seiner Energieversorgung auf Jahrzehnte
es sind seine Allmachtsfantasien wie ein
Geschwür breiten sie sich immer weiter
aus zerstören immer mehr die Beziehungen
zum Westen Vladimir Putin wünscht sich
sein Riesenreich die Halbinsel Krim
eigentlich ein Geschenk kruschtschows an
die Ukraine aber auch ein strategischer
Militärstützpunkt von Putin 2014
annektiert Russland die Krim eine
Reaktion auf den Kiefer euromeiter die
Annexion völkerrechtswidrig Putin
verletzt Grundprinzipien des
Völkerrechts stellt die europäische
Nachkriegsordnung in Frage es folgt
Krieg im Osten der Ukraine die
minsker-abkommen sollen den Konflikt
politisch lösen das Ziel Deeskalation
Frieden doch sie werden immer wieder
gebrochen Europa guckt tatenlos zu es
wird ein eingefrorener Konflikt aber
Putin verspricht die Ukraine nicht
weiter anzutasten
doch russlands Präsident lässt nicht
locker
zeigt seine eigentlichen Absichten 8
Jahre später greift er doch die Ukraine
an der Angriffskrieg im Februar 2022 der
Kreml des Boot erkennt die sogenannten
Volksrepubliken Don jetzt und luhans als
staatliche Einheiten an danach geht
alles ganz schnell zwei Tage später
besetzen russische Truppen einen Teil
des zweitgrößten Flächen Landes Europas
offizielle Truppen besetzen einen
unabhängigen europäischen Staat ein
Staat der UN-Mitglied ist seine unwahren
Behauptungen die ukrainische Regierung
misshandelt und ermordet jahrelang
Menschen
die Invasion beginnt
Putins dunkler Kern seine brutalen
Absichten sie finden den Weg an die
Oberfläche doch diesmal geben die
Ukrainer nicht auf sie beweisen einen
unbändigen Kampfes Willen Stück für
Stück er kämpfen sie sich ihr Land
zurück
David gegen Goliath die Ukraine gewinnt
im Angriffskrieg zunehmend die Oberhand
putinsieg immer unwahrscheinlicher er
steht mit dem Rücken zur Wand will den
Krieg schnellstmöglich beenden notfalls
nuklear die Welt in Angst
Wladimir vladimirovic Putin der Wolf im
Schafspelz die trojanische Matroschka
[Musik]